so in response
to your eloquent description of why AI
will kill us
Elon Musk replied on Twitter
okay so what should we do about it
question mark and you answered the game
board has already been played into a
frankly awful State there are not simple
ways to throw money at the problem if
anyone comes to you with a brilliant
solution like that please please talk to
me first
I can think of things that try they
don't fit in one tweet uh two questions
one why has the game board any of you
been played into an awful state would
just if you can give a little bit more
color to
uh the game board and the awful state of
the game board alignment is moving like
this
capabilities are moving like this
for The Listener capabilities are moving
much faster than the alignment
yeah all right so just the rate of
development attention interest
allocation of resources we could have
been working on this earlier people are
like oh but you know like how can you
possibly work on this earlier
because they wanted to they didn't want
to work on the problem they want an
excuse to wave it off they like said
like oh how can we possibly work on it
earlier and didn't spend five minutes
thinking about is there some way to work
on it earlier like we didn't like
and you know frankly it it would have
been hard you know like like can you
post bounties for half of the physics if
your planet is taking the stuff
seriously can you post bounties for like
half of the people wasting their lives
on string theory to like have gone into
this instead and like try to win a
billion dollars with a clever solution
only if you can tell which Solutions are
clever
which is which is hard
but you know the fact that it you know
we didn't take it seriously we didn't
try
it's not clear that we could have done
any better if we had you know it's not
clear how much progress we could have
produced if we had tried because it is
harder to produce Solutions but that
doesn't mean that you're like correct
and Justified and letting everything
slide it means that that things are in a
horrible State getting worse and there's
nothing you can do about it
so you're not there's no there's no like
uh there's no brain power
making progress in trying to figure out
how to align these systems you're not
investing money in it you're not you
don't have institution infrastructure
for uh like if you even if you invested
money in like Distributing that money
across the physicist system working on
string theory Brilliant Minds that are
working different how can you tell if
you're making progress you can like put
put them all on interpretability because
when you have an interpretability result
you can tell that it's there and there's
like but there's like you know
interpretability alone is not going to
save you
we need systems that will that will like
have a pause button where they won't try
to prevent you from pressing the pause
button
because we're like oh well like I can't
get it my stuff done if I'm paused
and that's like a more difficult problem
and
you know but it's like a fairly crisp
problem and you can like maybe tell if
somebody's made progress on it so you
can you can write and you can work on
the pause problem
I guess more generally uh the pause
button most generally you can call that
the control problem I don't actually
like the term control problem because
you know it sounds kind of controlling
and Alignment not control like you're
not trying to like take a thing that
disagrees with you and like whip it back
onto like like make it do what you
wanted to do even though it wants to do
something else you're trying to like
in the process of its creation choose
its direction sure but we currently in a
lot of the systems we design we do have
an off switch
that's that's a fundamental part of it's
not smart enough to to
prevent you from
pressing the off switch and probably not
smart enough to want to prevent you from
pressing the off switch so you're saying
the kind of systems we're talking about
the even the philosophical concept of an
off switch doesn't make any sense
because well no but off switch makes
sense they're just not opposing
your attempt to pull the off switch
parenthetically like
don't kill the system if you're like if
we're getting to the part where that
starts to actually matter and like where
they can fight back like don't kill them
and like dump their their memory like
like save them to disk don't kill them
you know be nice here uh well okay be
nice is a very interesting concept there
is we're talking about a system that can
do a lot of damage it's I don't know if
it's possible but it's certainly one of
the things you could try is to have an
off switch it's suspended to disc switch
you have this kind of romantic
attachment to the code yes if that makes
sense but if it's spreading
you don't want to spend to disk right
you you want this is there's something
fundamentally broken if it gets if it
gets that part of hand then like yes
pull the plugin then everything is
running on yes I think it's a research
question is it possible in AGI systems
AI systems to have a
uh sufficiently robust off switch they
cannot be manipulated they cannot be
manipulated by the AI system
the sound then it escapes from whichever
system you've built the almighty lever
into and copies itself somewhere else so
your answer to that research question is
no but I don't yeah but I don't know if
that's a hundred percent answer like I
don't know if it's obvious I think
you're
not putting yourself into the shoes of
the human in the world of glacially slow
aliens but the aliens built me let's
remember that
yeah so and they built the box I'm in
yeah
you're saying it's to me it's not
obvious they're slow and they're stupid
I'm not saying this is guaranteed I'm
saying it's non-zero probability it's an
interesting research question is it
possible when you're slow and stupid to
design a slow and stupid system that is
impossible to mess with the aliens being
as stupid as they are have actually put
you on Microsoft Azure Cloud servers
instead of this hypothetical perfect box
that's what happens when the aliens are
stupid
well but this is not AGI right this is
the early versions of the system as as
you start to yeah you think that they've
got like a plan where like they have
declared a a threshold level of
capabilities where past that
capabilities they move it off the cloud
servers and onto something that's air
gapped
I think there's a lot of people and
you're an important voice here there's a
lot of people that have that concern and
yes they will do that when there's an
uprising of public opinion the debt
needs to be done and when there's actual
little damage done with the holy
this system is beginning to manipulate
people then there's going to be an
uprising where there's going to be a
public pressure
and a public incentive in terms of
funding in developing things that can
off switch or developing aggressive
alignment mechanisms and no you're not
allowed to put on Azure aggressive
alignment mechanism for hell's
aggressive alignment mechanisms like it
doesn't matter if you say aggressive we
don't know how to do it
meaning aggressive alignment meaning you
have to
propose something otherwise you're not
allowed to put it on the cloud
the hell do you do you imagine they will
propose that would make it safe to put
something smarter than you on the cloud
that's what research is for why the
cynicism about such a thing not being
possible if you haven't done it works on
the first try
what so yes so yes again something
smarter than you so that's that is a
fundamental thing if it has to work on
the first if there's if if there's a
rapid takeoff
yes it's very difficult to do if there's
a rapid takeoff and the fundamental
difference between weak AGI and strong
agis you're saying that's going to be
extremely difficult to do if the public
Uprising never happens until you have
this critical phase shift then you're
right it's very difficult to do but
that's not obvious it's not obvious that
you're not going to start seeing
symptoms of the negative effects of AGI
to where you're like we have to put a
halt to this that there's not just first
try you get many tries at it yeah we can
like see right now that Bing is quite
difficult to align that when you try to
train inabilities into a system
into which capabilities have already
been trained that what do you know
gradient descent like learns small
shallow simple patches of inability and
you come in and ask it in a different
language and the Deep capabilities are
still in there and they evade the
shallow patches and come right back out
again there there you go there's there's
your there's your red fire alarm of like
oh no alignment is difficult is
everybody going to shut everything down
now
no that's not but that's not the same
kind of alignment A system that escapes
the box it's from is a fundamentally
different thing I think for you yeah not
but not for this so you put a line there
and everybody else puts a line somewhere
else and there's like yeah and there's
like no agreement
we we we have had a pandemic on this
planet with a few million people dead
which we will which we may never know
whether or not it was a lab leak because
there was definitely cover-up we don't
know that if there was a lab leak but we
know that the people who did the
research like you know like put out the
whole paper about this definitely wasn't
a lab leak and didn't reveal that they
had been doing had like sent off Chrono
fire coronavirus research to the we went
Institute of virology after it was
banned in the United States after the
Ganda function research was temporarily
banned in the United States and the same
people who exported a gain of function
research on coronaviruses to the wunhan
Institute of virology after it would
began a function that gained event gain
of function research was temporarily
banned in the United States are now
getting more grants
to do more research on a gain of
function research on coronaviruses
maybe we do better in this than in AI
but like this is not something we cannot
take for granted that there's going to
be an outcry
yeah people have different thresholds
for when they start to outcry
ptable granted but I I think your
intuition is that there's a very high
probability that this event happens
without us solving the alignment problem
and I guess that's where I'm trying to
build up more uh perspectives and color
on this intuition is it possible that
the probability is not something like
100 but it's like 32 percent
that uh AI will escape the Box before we
solve the alignment problem not solve
but is it possible we always stay ahead
of the AI in terms of our ability to
solve for that particular system the
alignment problem nothing like the world
in front of us right now
you've already seen it that that that
gpt4 is not turning out this way
and there are like basic obstacles where
you've got the the weak version of the
system that doesn't know enough to
deceive you and the strong version of
the system that could deceive you if it
wanted to do that it feels already like
sufficiently unaligned to want to
deceive you there's the question of like
how on the current Paradigm you train
honesty when the humans can no longer
tell if the system is being honest
you don't think these are research
questions that could be answered I think
they could be the answer to 50 years
with unlimited retries the way things
usually work in science
I just disagree with that you're making
it 50 years I think with the kind of
attention this guest with the kind of
funding I guess it could be answered uh
not in whole but in incrementally within
within months and within a small number
of years if it's a if it's at scale
receives attention and research so if
you start studying large language models
I think there was an intuition like two
years ago even that something like gpt4
the current capabilities of even Chad
GPT with GPT 3.5 is not is gonna we're
still far away from that I think a lot
of people are surprised by the
capabilities of gpt4 right so now people
are waking up okay we need to study
these language models I think there's
going to be a lot of interesting
AI Safety Research are the are Earth's
billionaires going to put up like the
the giant prizes that would maybe
incentivize young hot shot people who
just got their physics degrees to not go
to the hedge funds and instead put
everything into interpretability in this
like one small area where we can
actually tell whether or not somebody
has made a discovery or not I think so
because uh
well that's what these these
conversations are about because they're
going to wake up to the fact that gpt4
can be used to manipulate elections to
influence geopolitics to influence the
economy there's a lot of there's going
to be a huge amount of incentive to like
wait a minute we can't this has to be we
have to put we have to make sure they're
not doing damage we have to make sure we
interpretability we have to make sure we
don't understand how these systems
function so that we can predict their
effect on economy so that there's uh so
there's a feudalism and a bunch of
op-eds in the new New York Times and
nobody actually stepping forth and
saying you know what instead of a mega
yacht I'd rather put that billion
dollars on prizes for young Hotshot
physicists who make fundamental
breakthroughs in interpretability
the yacht versus the interpretability
research the old uh the old trade-off
uh
I I just I think uh it's just I think
there's going to be a huge amount of
allocation of funds I hope I guess you
want to bet me on that
but you want to put a time scale on it
say how much funds you think are going
to be allocated in a direction that I
would consider to be actually useful
by what time
I do think there will be a huge amount
of funds
but you're saying it needs to be open
right the development of the system
should be closed but the development of
the the interpretability research the
Aisa we are so far behind on inter under
under interpretability compared to
capabilities like yeah you could take
the last generation of systems the the
stuff that's already in the open there
is so much in there that we don't
understand there are so many prizes you
could do before you you know you could
you could you would have enough insights
that you'd be like oh you know like well
we understand how these systems work we
understand how these things are doing
their outputs we can read their minds
now let's try it with the bigger systems
yeah we're nowhere near that you you
there's so much interpretability work to
be done on the weaker versions of the
systems so what what can you say on the
second point you said to uh uh to Elon
Musk on what are some ideas what are
things you could try I can think of a
few things I try you said they don't fit
in one tweet so is there something you
could put into words of the things you
would try
I mean
the the the the trouble is the stuff is
subtle I've watched people try to make
progress on this and not get places
somebody who just like gets alarmed and
charges in it's like going nowhere
sure it meant like years ago about I
don't know like 20 years 15 years
something like that I was talking to a
congress person
um
who
had become alarmed about the eventual
prospects and he wanted
work on building AIS without emotions
because the emotional AIS were the scary
ones you see
and some poor person at arpa had come up
with a research proposal whereby this
congressman's panic and desire to fund
this thing would go into something that
the person at arpa thought would be
useful and had been munched around to
where it would like sound the
congressman like work was happening on
this which you know of course like this
is just the the Congress person had
misunderstood the problem
and did not understand where the danger
came from
and
so it's like that the issue is that
you could like do this in a certain
precise way and maybe get something like
when I say like put up prizes on
interpretability I'm not I'm like well
like
because it's verifiable there as opposed
to other places you can tell whether or
not good work actually happened in this
exact narrow case if you do things in
exactly the right way you can maybe
throw money at it and produce
science instead of anti-science and
nonsense
and all the all the methods that I know
of of like trying to throw money at this
problem have this share this property of
like well if you do it exactly right
based on understanding exactly what has
you know like tends to produce like
useful outputs or not then you can like
add money to it in this way now there's
like and the thing that I'm giving as an
example here in front of this large
audience is is the most understandable
of those
because there's like other people
who you know like like like Chris Ola
and and even and even more generally
like you can tell whether or not
interpretability progress has occurred
so like if I say Throw money at
producing more interpretability there's
like a chance somebody can do it that
way and like it will actually produce
useful results then the other stuff just
blurs often to be like harder to Target
exactly than that
so sometimes the basics are fun to
explore because they're not so basic
what do you what is interpretability
what do you what does it look like what
are we talking about it looks like
we took a much smaller
set of Transformer layers than the ones
in the modern bleeding edge state of the
art systems
and after applying nefarious
tools and mathematical ideas and trying
20 different things we found we have
shown it that this piece of the system
is doing this kind of useful work
and then somehow also hopefully
generalizes some fundamental
understanding of what's going on that
generalizes to the bigger system
you can hope and it's probably true like
you would not expect the smaller tricks
to go away when you have a system that's
like doing larger kinds of work you
would expect the larger work kinds of
work to be building on top of the
smaller kinds of work and gradient
descent runs across the smaller kinds of
work before it runs across the larger
kinds of work and well that's kind of
what is happening in Neuroscience right
it's trying to understand the human
brain by prodding and it's such a giant
mystery and people have made progress
even though it's extremely difficult to
make sense of what's going on in the
brain they have different parts of the
brain they're responsible for hearing
for Sight the vision science Community
that's understanding visual cortex that
I mean they've made a lot of progress in
understanding how that stuff works like
and that's I guess but you're saying it
takes a long time to do that work well
also it's not enough so in particular
um
let's say you have got your
interpretability
tools and they say that your
current AI system is plotting to kill
you
now what
it is definitely a good step one right
yeah what's step two
if you cut out that layer is it going to
stop
waiting to kill you when you optimize
against visible
misalignment you are optimizing against
misalignment and you are also optimizing
against visibility
so sure you can yeah it's true all
you're doing is removing the obvious
intentions to kill you you've got your
detector it's showing something inside
the system that you don't like okay say
the disaster monkey is running this
thing
will optimize the system until the
visible bad behavior goes away
but it's arising for fundamental reasons
of instrumental convergence the old you
can't bring the coffee if you're dead
any goal and you know almost any set of
almost every set of utility functions
with a few narrow exceptions implies
killing all the humans
but do you think it's possible because
we can do experimentation to discover
the source of the desire to kill
I can tell it to you right now is that
it wants to do something
and the way to get the most of that
thing is to put the universe into a
state where there aren't humans
so is it is it possible to encode
in the same way we think like why do we
think murder is wrong the same
foundational
ethics
it's not hard-coded in but more like
deeper I mean that's part of the
research how do you have it that this
Transformer
this small
version of the language model doesn't
ever want to kill
that'd be nice assuming that you got
doesn't want to kill sufficiently
exactly right that it didn't be like oh
I will like detach their heads and put
them in some jars and keep the heads
alive forever and then go do the thing
but leaving that aside well not leaving
that aside yeah that's a strong point
yeah because there is a whole issue
where as something gets smarter it finds
ways of achieving the same goal
predicate that we're not imaginable to
stupider versions of the system or
perhaps the stupider operators that's
one of many things making this difficult
a larger thing making this difficult is
that we do not know how to get any goals
into systems at all we know how to get
outwardly observable behaviors into
systems we do not know how to get
internal psychological wanting to do
particular things into the system that
is not what the current technology does
I mean it could be things like
um dystopian Futures like Brave New
World
where most humans will actually say we
kind of want that future it's a great
future everybody's happy
we would have to get so far
self much further than we are now
and further faster before that failure
mode became a running concern
your failure modes are much much more
drastic the ones you know the failure
modes are much simpler it's it's like
yeah like the AI puts the universe into
a particular state it happens to not
have any humans inside it okay so the
paperclip maximizer
utility so the original version of the
paperclip Max can you explain it if you
can okay
the original version was you lose
control of the utility function and it
so happens that what maxes out the
utility per unit resources is Tiny
molecular shapes like paper clips
there's a lot of things that make it
happy but the cheapest one that didn't
saturate was
putting matter into certain shapes
and it so happens that that the cheapest
way to make these shapes is to make them
very small because then you need fewer
atoms for instance of the shape and
arguendo I S you know like it happens to
look like a paper clip in retrospect I
wish I'd said Tiny molecular spirals or
like tiny molecular hyperbolic spirals
why because I said a tiny molecular
paper clips this got heard as this got
then mutated to paper clips this then
mutated it too and the AI was in a
paperclip Factory
so the original story is about how you
lose control of the system it doesn't
want what you tried to make it want the
thing that that it ends up wanting most
is a thing that even from a very
embracing Cosmopolitan perspective we
think of as having no value and that's
how the value of the future gets
destroyed then that got changed to a
fable of like well you made a paperclip
Factory and it did exactly what you
wanted what you wanted but you asked it
to do the wrong thing which is a
completely different failure
but those are both concerns to you so
that's more than a Brave New World yeah
if you can solve the problem of making
something want
exactly what you wanted to want then you
got to deal with the problem of wanting
the right thing
But first you have to solve the
alignment first you have to solve inner
alignment inner alignment then you get
to solve outer alignment
like first you need to be able to point
the insides of the thing in a direction
and then you get to to deal with whether
that direction expressed in reality is
like the thing that aligned with the
thing that you want
are you scared
of this whole thing
probably I
don't really know
what gives you hope about this
possibility of being wrong
not that you're right but we will
actually get our act together and
allocate a lot of resources to the
alignment problem well I can easily
imagine that at some point this Panic
expresses itself in the waste of a
billion dollars
spending a billion dollars correctly
that's harder
to solve both the inner and the outer
alignment if you're wrong to solve a
number of things yeah number of things
if you're wrong
what why what do you think would be the
reason like if 50 years from now not
perfectly wrong you know you make a lot
of really eloquent points you know this
there's a lot of like shape to the ideas
you express but like if if you're
somewhat wrong about some fundamental
ideas why would that be
stuff has to be easier than than I think
it is
you know when the first time you're
building a rocket
being wrong isn't a certain sense quite
easy
happening to be wrong in a way where the
rocket goes twice as far and half the
fuel and lands exactly where you hoped
it would
most cases of being wrong make it harder
to build a rocket harder to have it not
explode cause it to require more fuel
than you hoped cause it to be land off
Target
being wrong in a way that's mixed stuff
easier you know that's that's not the
usual project management story yeah